this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
andrew garfield he's an award-winning
actor a handsome british man a massive
fan of spider-man and he secured a
distant third place otherwise known as
last place against the likes of tom
holland and toby maguire on a twitter
poll that asked you guys who your
favorite spider-man was like it wasn't
even close last week i spent about an
hour talking to you all about why i
loved the raimi films and it even
managed to last about 50 minutes before
getting a copyright claim so that was
fun not like it's a time of year where i
need to pay for stuff or anything
patreon.com forward slash totally not
mark
similar to the raimi trilogy i hadn't
seen the amazing spider-man films since
they were in theaters which means in the
case of the first one i hadn't seen it
in like 10 years while raymond's trilogy
was full of good memories my feelings
towards these marked web films before
reacquainting myself with them spanned
from indifference to genuine distaste
because i was 20 years old when i last
saw these films i felt as though i
remembered quite a lot but boy was i in
for a surprise so sit back relax and
enjoy the emotional the intense the
shocking the amazing spider-man when
life leaves you high and dry i'll be at
your door tonight if you need help
if you need help
that you will do the same for me
and i will do it having not seen these
films since i was in college i was eager
to see if my lukewarm feelings towards
them would have changed now that i'm in
a completely different part of my life
with an entirely different set of
expectations going into this reboot of
spider-man i like many my age at the
time felt like it needed to live up to
or exceed what the raimi trilogy
achieved and in retrospect i think
that's an entirely unfair expectation to
lay at the feet of mark webb and this
first film the amazing spider-man for
the most part nowadays these films
aren't remembered too fondly by the
majority of spider-man fans and i think
i was in the same boat before revisiting
them i was 20 years old then and now
having sat down to watch these once
again in my 30s i gotta be honest while
i can still see some significant issues
with these movies on a narrative level
and even a fundamental spider-man one i
can confidently say that largely i was
wrong and so while we dive into these
films i'd like us to do so with an open
mind typically when it comes to these
reviews i try to give the director and
screenplay the benefit of the doubt
where i can trying to best connect with
and understand the story they were
trying to tell and the first step in
doing so is to try and remember what the
ecosystem of hollywood 2012 looked like
since the release of the dark knight in
2008 one year after the last remy film
it was clear to see the motivation for
sony to move on to something more in
keeping with what they figured the
global zeitgeist was begging for a more
realistic approach to the wall crawler
and with that mindset in place it
ushered in with it a new era of
superhero flicks that tried to focus in
on and capture the qualities that made
the dark knight trilogy so successful
with a younger generation a gritty more
character-driven and realistic story
which if this wasn't already apparent
made for an impossible set of
circumstances for this film to succeed
with in the first place and what i mean
by that is i can't speak to everyone's
impression of the remy films and i won't
but the impression i've received over
the years from talking to and asking
many people questions about spider-man
and what that character ought to be more
often than not it seems like sam raimi's
films and indeed more modern
interpretations of the character are
seen as the quote definitive version or
iteration of peter parker and spider-man
and as such everything else that's new
needs to live up to those expectations
which i can't say i agree with at all i
mean toby maguire's peter parker in the
first place isn't anything like the
original comics interpretation of the
character and i'm not going to knock him
for that because it doesn't need to be
and i thought sam raimi's version of the
characters served his film series well
however i believe despite it not being
his intention to do so sam brain be
created for an entire generation of
people an image of spider-man that they
saw as the quote definitive version and
truthfully looking back on how i felt at
the time this particular line of
thinking rings true for how i was
feeling back then but not today and i
think that's the main reason why i left
this film very satisfied so let's dive
into it with an open mind and see how my
opinions regarding this film have
remained the same and how they've
significantly changed also starting with
andrew garfield's peter parker
put him down
eugene
peter parker this is probably the most
controversial aspect of this series of
films and where i think i too had the
most issue when i saw it in college i
touched on this briefly in my sam remy
video but toby's incarnation of the
character while loved by many should not
be but often is seen as the definitive
version of the peter parker character
and i feel like it shouldn't be seen as
such primarily because a if you're a
comic book purist you'll realize sam
raimi's version isn't an accurate
portrayal of the character and his
personality from the original run of the
comics and b i think as cultures and
sensibilities surrounding different
characters change so too must the
characters to some degree in order to
make sense in and appeal to that
generation or world going into this film
mark webb off the back of directing 500
days of summer a character-driven
comedic drama was hired to direct a
spider-man film with those same
realistic dramatic sensibilities in
order to capture what he was told an
audience was clamoring for in his own
way and with all of that taken into
consideration what i'm about to say
might sound like a cardinal sin but i
not only think andrew garfield is a
great spider-man like many do but i also
think he's a good and sometimes great
peter parker toby mcguire and sam
raimi's version of peter parker comes
across like a quiet meek but otherwise
pleasant fellow and that serves his
stories well however when you compare
him to the original run of the comics
peter parker the difference has become
much more pronounced in the comics peter
is rogue short-tempered and resentful at
times his story isn't like toby's where
a good guy becomes vengeful and then
becomes a good guy again instead the
original origin of peter parker tells
the story of an outsider one that was
able to speak up for himself but never
had the power to enact his will unto the
world a bully victim that would be a
bully if he had the power which in
effect makes the story of responsibility
so powerful in those early comics
powerful because peter parker isn't the
sort of person who would naturally adopt
responsibility remind you of anyone
hey parker
not today flash hey come on man i just
want to talk
this isn't a recreation of toba
mcguire's version of peter park this is
someone else someone that's much closer
to what peter was in the original run of
the comics in the 60s furthermore during
the director's commentary for the first
film toby confessed when questioned by
jk simmons about his experience with the
character of spider-man growing up that
he in fact shared no connection with him
at all he wasn't really a fan of the
character and in preparation for the
role had to read 100 issues of the
original comics run to prepare this is
perfectly fine of course however it
stands in direct contrast with andrew
garfield's experience no i don't i don't
know about the cool thing there's an
outsider quality that i wanted to to
achieve that resilient orphan that that
that's able to you know like that that
has a that has a kind of defensiveness
and a difficult difficult to access
aspect um
so so there was that and and you know
there's so much dimension to peter
parker he's i think he finds a
confidence when he when he finds his
power and that may be the call you're
speaking of that he he accesses a
a kind of a rebelliousness
that um that he hadn't been able to
access before there are countless
interviews from this time period with
garfield showing us all that he's not
only intimately aware of what makes
peter parker tick but also that he's a
massive fan of this character he
sincerely felt a tremendous amount of
pressure not just from the rest of the
world but from himself he knows what
this character means to everyone because
it means a lot to him and whether you
prefer toby's interpretation of peter
parker or not andrew garfield's
performance i think as both peter parker
and spider-man is unrivaled in terms of
authenticity the toby films really
didn't spend a lot of time on the origin
of spider-man becoming spider-man with
him immediately going into superhero
mode once he's faced with uncle ben's
killer which is fantastic for that film
as that's what the film is about it's a
camp hokey caricature and romanticized
reimagining of both new york city and
the story of peter parker the monologues
from villains mentors and heroes in
these films follow more closely with a
shakespearean drama than a realistic
interpretation of any character or
location the amazing spider-man on the
other hand tries to make peter parker
feel like a real human being like the
original comics he's angry he's rogish
he's ego driven he's resentful he's
flirtatious and most importantly he's
not naturally virtuous i've heard people
complain about this particular aspect of
his character that he's not really a
nice guy that he's kind of an [ __ ]
and that's the point this is a lesson a
transformation that he's supposed to
undergo himself in order to become
spider-man which is perfect as that's
exactly what this film is about and
where i think its greatest strengths lie
[Music]
it's gonna got a lot worse becoming
spider-man peter parker is just the
foundation of this story and
faithfulness to the comics alone does
not make for a good story things can be
accurate all they like but if the core
story being told is told poorly or
doesn't hit the right notes at the right
time for the audience then there's a
problem and while there are problems
that exist with this film that i will
most definitely be speaking on later
they have absolutely nothing to do with
peter parker spider-man or andrew
garfield's portrayal of either in my
opinion in fact there is a 40-minute
stretch in this film where i sincerely
believe it's almost perfect telling a
very human story of ego and how it can
fool you into thinking that you're doing
the right thing when in actuality all
you're doing is indulging in a selfish
desire i just did 80 of your job huh
that that's how you repay me the portion
of this film that won me over as a
spider-man fan starts here when peter
powers in all of return home to an angry
uncle ben which by the way is something
to address quickly despite the clumsy
means with which he's written off to die
i love martin sheen's performance here
as uncle ben this iteration on the uncle
ben character feels more fleshed out
with a more human quality to him he's
visibly flawed prone to anger gets
confused and is openly self-conscious
concerning his lack of education
particularly towards his adopted son
peter but at his core he's an honest man
that deeply cares for his son and so in
the same way aunt may's character
reminded me of my grandmother in the
rainy trilogy this ben parker reminds me
of my grandfather but i digress peter
fails to uphold the responsibility that
was given to him by ben to look after
his wife may which leads to a monologue
that is often criticized online today
the quote goes your father believed that
if you could do good things for other
people then you had a moral obligation
to do those things that's what's at
stake here not choice responsibility and
to tell you the truth despite the
original uncle ben not actually saying
with great power comes great
responsibility line in the comics this
still comes across and hits me like a
change that was made purely to
differentiate itself from the remy films
and i don't know i don't really like it
but i can take it or leave it it's not a
big deal following this heated and
ultimately final interaction between
these two characters a similar series of
moral mistakes are committed by peter to
create this scene and this is where the
raimi films and this web film differ in
the best of ways you see instead of
immediately learning this lesson
following this mistake he instead tries
to right the wrong he feels in his heart
he feels guilty and now motivated to
hunt down and take revenge to restore
balance to the world he thinks and this
this is the portion of the film and
indeed the story most people take issue
with and to be quite honest i can see
why he comes off as quippy yes but
there's a real air of ignorant
uncompassionate and perhaps egotistical
heroics if you can even call it that he
dons the mask not to save people or to
do the right thing but to exact his
revenge onto the man who took his uncle
from him and this is the first time we
see him in the suit too further rubbing
salt onto the wounds of fans that did
not see this as their spiderman but and
this is where i make my feelings known
concerning this choice i think this is
the single best decision ever made in a
spider-man film one that not only works
for this movie but feels so incredibly
faithful to the spirit of this character
in ways no other live-action film has
managed to achieve for the character of
peter parker and indeed spider-man
extending and by virtue of it
highlighting the qualities that make
spider-man spider-man in toby's films
the origin of spider-man was actually
quite short and that's one of the film's
strengths i think there's a concerted
effort to establish numerous moving
parts in the first half hour of that
film and really by the time the first
hour is over spider-man has in a sense
reached his final form however when it
comes to andrew garfield's amazing
spider-man run there's so much more
detail and nuance to his development so
much so that the entire first film is
about his origin that's the focus of the
film and in the spirit of that i'm sure
many of you that are familiar might be
able to pinpoint the moment andrew
garfield's peter parker finally becomes
spider-man on the bridge saving that
small child and while that scene is
spectacular and one of my favorites in
these films it's not the best scene in
this movie and it's not where he becomes
spider-man instead
it's here who's assaulting civilians in
the dead of night is assault is
assaulting people
i'm not sure i mean i i think most
people would say that he was
providing a public service this is the
single most important scene not only in
this film but perhaps in all of andrew
garfield's spider-man films and i'll
explain why this is the scene where all
the stories themes are explored laid to
bear and most importantly this is the
scene where spider-man is born peter is
extremely combative and defensive on
these talking points defending
spider-man's actions as helpful and
virtuous while stacy makes his stance
firmly disagreeing with peters and thus
an argument ensues the best scenes in
cinema i think come from two people in a
room talking to each other everything
else is just set dressing for the
audience and this is a tremendous
example of how terrific and powerful the
scene can be with just two people
exchanging points of view the argument
begins with peter taking the side of
spider-man espousing his virtues all the
while gwen's father explains why
everything peter is saying is either
driven by ego or just wrong
if i wanted the car thief off the street
he'd already be off the street the car
thief was leading us to the people who
run the entire operation and that's a
big hit for peter the look on his face
when stacy talks about strategy and how
spider-man ruined that opportunity for
them says it all peter's not stupid so
why didn't he think of this the police
had their own plans which would have
yielded a better result for the city at
large in the long run so he should have
thought of that right well
obviously he didn't know he had a plan
for a large portion of this conversation
peter tries to defer responsibility
deflect fault and excuse any mistake
spider-man might have made that is until
this scene reaches its brilliant turning
point i think he stands for what you
stand for sir
protecting innocent people from bad guys
i stand for law and order son that's
what i stand for okay i wear a badge
this guy wears a mask like uh you know
like a like an outlaw he's hunting down
a bunch of criminals that all look the
same like he's got some sort of personal
vendetta but he's not protecting
innocent people mr parker this scene
encapsulates this entire film and
precisely pinpoints the epiphany that
transforms peter from a rogue terrorist
to a friendly neighborhood spider-man
heck it's this very conversation which
drags him onto the roof where he feels
gwen in on his identity and senses
danger on the bridge where the lizard is
causing havoc a brilliant example of
cause and effect in film peter learns
the error of his ways gets excused from
dinner and as a result of being excused
reveals his identity to gwen and puts
himself into the perfect position to
save people
what a brilliant scene and it's by far
my favorite in this film as the icing
and cherry on this proverbial cake comes
this bridge scene if the previous dinner
scene was the sequence in which peter
became spider-man this is the scene
where peter proves it up until now peter
had been capturing bad guys almost with
the laser focus however not because he
wanted to do right by the citizens of
the city he grew up with but instead to
satisfy his own selfish desires for
revenge and recognition it's a fault
born out of a lack of adult guidance and
naivety this is on full display in the
scene where he takes out the car thief
and deals with the police officer that
arrives on the scene he's totally blown
away by the fact that the cops want to
seize both him and the car thief and in
response leans into this arrogance and
narcissist and it's this very character
trait that the original comics utilized
to make the themes of responsibility so
powerful transforming a young troubled
and irresponsible teen into a
responsible young adult capable of
maximizing the good he's capable of and
this bridge scene demonstrates that
perfectly catching cars as they're about
to fall at first in pursuit of the
lizard in order to apprehend him however
eventually despite getting the perfect
opportunity to chase after a weakened
lizard peter volunteers his time instead
to stay behind and save a young boy in a
burning car hanging from the bridge the
scene in question is incredibly
endearing and intimate andrew garfield
demonstrates once again why he's one of
the most underrated actors in hollywood
and delivers one of the most powerful
scenes in any spider-man film showing us
and indeed peter that he is capable of
instilling so much more strength into
others by simply making the right
choices and that's the best part of this
film that stretch from uncle ben's
confrontation with peter to this moment
on the bridge it's a stunningly perfect
depiction of spider-man's origin with a
teen that isn't naturally inclined to
adopt responsibility and it's given me
chills in ways no other spider-man film
has managed to do to date
happy new year we're treating 2022 as a
fresh start here in the channel and that
means a new me thanks to manscaped if
you're looking to overhaul yourself too
then the awesome performance package 4.0
has everything you need the lawnmower
4.0 is the highlight of this package
this cordless trimmer is not only
waterproof and great for sensitive skin
thanks to its skin safe tech but it also
features a fancy led light that's
perfect for getting an eye in on those
hard to reach areas and with valentine's
on the horizon you better make sure
those areas smell great flowers and
chocolate are a great start but wouldn't
she also love you if you treated
yourself with a crop preserver and crop
reviver that's right this kit comes with
handy ball deodorant and ball toner
spray to ensure you smell great for
valentine's day and hey if the tickle of
your nose hair bothers her in your more
intimate moments the weed whacker nose
and ear trimmer has you covered too 360
degree rotary blades and the same skin
safe tech from the trimmer this thing is
wonderful every guy needs to add
manscape to their wishlist this
valentine's day and if you've got a
special man in your life who needs a
good cleanup then make sure you get him
this awesome performance package it even
comes with a free travel bag and
anti-chafing boxers it'll look totally
innocent and not as though you think he
smells so don't worry go to manscape.com
and use my promo code not mark 20 to get
20 off plus free international shipping
and 2 free gifts
the amazing spider-man films boasts two
separate suits one for the first film
and one for the second everyone loves
the second suit and so do i it's
beautiful slightly more flamboyant and
overall i think it's a little more
iconic look if that makes any sense at
all but i think there's a lot of
brilliance in the first film and what
the suit offers the story in terms of
authenticity in the context of the film
for instance a guiding philosophy in the
creation of this first film on behalf of
mark webb was to breathe a sense of
realism into the story the likes of
which we've seldom seen in the past the
sam remy films as i mentioned were a
melodramatic almost shakespeareanly camp
rump the likes of which worked for that
universe but were a far cry from what
mark webb was famous for with the
previous film 500 days of summer instead
he wanted to focus on the interpersonal
relationships of key characters to
inform and progress the narrative with a
far more cerebral touch that created at
least for me a more realistic world to
inhabit technology is everywhere in this
film laptops phones tablets earbuds bing
these were all conscious decisions made
that help to bring this world more in
line with their own apart from bing
compare that to the set from toby
maguire's universe and comparatively
they looked like their time capsules set
in the 60s however as many of you might
have noticed one of my main issues with
the mask seen in the samurai trilogy was
how often it would build or stunt the
performance of the man beneath the mask
i'm not interested in seeing a mannequin
perform an emote i want to see the
emotion translate effectively through
the suit to match the scene and again as
i said in the first tobii video one of
the main factors preventing these
performances from reaching the next
level were the face shields it creates a
nice head shape yes but it also causes
this scene to feel like it's dubbed in
the worst way possible don't do it
goblin with the same level of emotion
translating in the elevator scene from
the second film and i'm really only
picking on spider-man in this instance
in these films because you can see
defoe's eyes and mouth most of the time
in this movie and the rest of the
villains in these films are either
completely cgi or they're not wearing
masks at all so why do i think the
approach taken for the amazing
spider-man suit works better well two
reasons or should i say
two people primarily andrew garfield is
a godsend when it comes to physically
communicating emotion he knows that he
can't emote with his face and so he
overcompensates through his own
physicality when i revisited these films
garfield's vocal and physical
performances i feel made toby's look
amateur by comparison now that's not to
say toby's was bad at all i don't think
that was the case in fact i think toby
walks so that andrew and tom could run
in this regard however in this film gone
are the hands held down by their sides
in some static position and now was a
much more dynamic performance than not
only communicated personality but intent
and character in this scene we get to
see peter parker's flaws plane as day
this isn't a young man interested in
justice and good but instead someone
that's looking to embarrass his targets
and get revenge and due to the efficacy
of this performance andrew managed to
convey the exact results necessary to
make the detective stacey dinner scene
work and by extension the entire film
work and while this perspective or
opinion on the mask might not be popular
or often spoken about online it's 100
something the actors and stuntmen on
these films have had to contend with and
try to figure out during their
respective runs david ellison has been
the primary spider-man stuntman since
2012. he's appeared donning the mask in
both sony's amazing spider-man and the
mcu's incarnation of the character and
in comparing his experience in working
with these two universes he specifically
outlined mark webb's desire for a much
more serious and realistic take on the
character remarking that a substantial
amount of time and focus had been placed
on moving more quote spider-like versus
the much more laid-back approach in the
original toby films and the greater
focus on exaggerated character acting in
the mcu incarnation of the character
each has their pros and cons however i
truly loved andrew and david's
performance as spider-man in these
amazing spider-man films it really
served to bring the character to life in
a way that helped to alleviate some of
the downsides wearing the mask had
brought for me at least in the past
i really enjoyed reese fans dr kirk
connors and his eventual spiral into
becoming the lizard i thought many of
the visuals and much of the dialogue he
was given helped to humanize and
establish his motivations early on and
despite this section feeling somewhat
similar to norman osborn's
transformation to green goblin i felt as
though this rang true to webb's mission
to ground this character in reality or
as much reality as a giant evil lizard
man could possibly grant
i long to fix myself i want to create a
world without weakness
similar to raimi's approach to tackling
these villains dr connors 2 expresses
his key motivations behind his actions
in this film long before he becomes the
lizard which speaks to this aspect of
his personality being present
irrespective of the lizard's influence
however the scene where this key
character moment takes place shares a
considerable amount of time and focus
with peter and gwen within which peter's
situation and his budding relationship
with gwen stacy receives much of the
focus and honestly i'm undecided if
that's a good or a bad thing in this
instance peter's relationship with gwen
isn't just a cornerstone of this one
film but really his entire character
across the films he's participated in it
defines him however somewhat troublingly
i find myself comparing dr connor's
treatment in this film to osborne's in
the first of ramey's osborne despite not
having direct ties to peter at first
shares the screen with him only five
minutes into the movie the two of them
receive a tremendous amount of screen
time together and separately with norman
eventually filling the void in peter's
life left behind by his uncle ben
leading to that supremely cathartic and
emotionally powerful conclusive scene
where peter rejects norman's way of life
in the name of remembering and valuing
what his uncle stood for however in this
film despite it trying to feel more raw
and real it felt at least to me
noticeably hollow by comparison we don't
see kurt until 17 minutes into this film
and when we do the focus is still on
peter and gwen with the main connective
tissue and first real conversation
between kirk connors and peter coming 30
minutes into the film by way of
peter's parents
now i haven't spoken about peter
parker's parents in this review yet and
that's by design i think a lot of people
have lambasted these films in the past
and in many ways deservedly so however i
think there's far more positives to
these films than the few poor choices
that have ultimately and sadly defined
these films which is why i've spent so
long singing this film's praises however
in the interest of balance and well
honesty peter's parents are the single
worst inclusion in not just this film
but also the second unfortunately with
the second film's inclusion in my
opinion fundamentally destroying
everything i love about this spider-man
character in this film they only serve
to act as a rather boring motivator
enticing peter to unearth secrets about
his past in other words they act as a
loose motivation to push the plot
forward that really the audience or at
least me did not care about and most
importantly they don't seem to in any
meaningful way influence who peter
parker is nearly as much as his uncle
ben and aunt may do in this film which
would be great if not for how this
impacts the lizard kurt connors as many
of you are aware unlike norman in the
first raimi film who played a diametric
opposition to uncle ben in those movies
dr kirk connors doesn't have that same
thematic connection his connection to
peter is through the comparatively much
less interesting relatable and weaker
richard parker character whom we don't
know anything about we've not seen him
spend any time with his son and his only
line in this film so far has been this
and we're supposed to care about this
connection to peter parker's character
because of this i don't know with that
said despite my indifferences to peter's
parents in these films as i mentioned dr
connors does receive a proper character
rich scene about half an hour into this
film where he does get to express his
regret and history with peter's father
and in this he comes across wonderfully
well and genuine a man angry at the
prospect of coming so close to achieving
his dreams and realizing this anger he
felt distracted him from what he should
have done for peter and his family and
so unlike norman and befitting of webb's
more realistic vision for this film dr
curtis connors comes across as a
complicated and nuanced character that
while dealing with some questionable
anger beneath the surface harboring
resentment for what he has to deal with
he still has a decency to him and an
interest in helping peter where he can
interestingly on an aesthetic front in
looking through the behind the scenes
for this film there was a clear passion
behind the search for a suitable
depiction of the lizard character also
creating a flatter rounder head that
would allow for more believable
communication and speech while also
keeping reese's eyes to ensure that his
humanity would always shine through in
his performance and yet despite this
version of the character having had a
tremendous amount of research and care
put into it i've also noticed that much
of the discourse surrounding it is
criticizing the missing long snout and
lab coat that was part of the 90s
incarnation of the character and again
it feels like everyone's modern opinion
or vision of spider-man seems to come
from either the raimi films or that 90's
cartoon which is fine if that's your
preference but i think it's also okay to
point out that the original run for the
lizard in the spider-man comics depicted
him as something very close to what we
got in this film flat face and all
something you might have noticed about
this video is that i've spoken very
little about emma stone and her
portrayal of the competent and endearing
queen stacey who plays a surprisingly
large and important role in this climax
alongside peter making her the objective
best love interest represented in these
live-action films no this is not up for
debate and no i will not be taking
questions at this time
but jokes aside with that said i do want
to give her her own section when
discussing the amazing spider-man 2
later on and all that comes with that so
don't worry i will be talking about her
contribution to these films in due time
i think looking back on my time watching
these films as a 20 year old young adult
one of the final nails in the coffin for
me was how flaccid this conclusion to
the film felt in comparison to toby's
films which always felt like they tried
to end on a profound culmination of
everything those films had been building
up to across their respective run times
and while this film does try to do just
that what with a brilliant reveal of his
identity to gwen's father a callback to
the bridge scene where the boy's father
helps him reach the lizard and of course
a great team-up between gwen's father
and peter at the end however due to
issues i alluded to earlier what with
kurt connor's frankly perplexing plan to
turn the city into lizards a plan so
silly it's only made feel even sillier
thanks to the realistic film webb tried
to make and of course
we have peter's parents who as i
mentioned only serve to take weight away
from the scene by making kurt less
significant in peter's life in addition
to all of that even in some of the cute
callbacks like the guy doing spidey a
solid for saving his kid by lifting him
on cranes compare that to the rally that
new york had for peter in the first toby
film coincidentally on the bridge too it
just felt lifeless in comparison and it
didn't hit the mark in the uplifting way
it was aiming for i think and really
this was one of the few things i didn't
change my opinion on from the first time
i watched this versus now
however with all of that negativity
aside i still have a lot of time for
this film and this ending i felt that
while conor largely didn't work as
effectively as he perhaps could have he
did contribute to some memorable scenes
and perhaps the most memorable stan lee
cameo he offered a tenderness to the
role that really added much needed
humanity and nuance to the scenes he
participated in and of course i am a big
fan of the design with all of that said
however captain stacy is still the man
who steals this film he's a rock of a
character that breeds so much stoicism
and grit into the script elevating
already great scenes to something far
more than the sum of their parts his
confrontation with peter once he learns
his identity is powerful and his request
of peter to stay out of gwen's life is
both wise and informs the next film
tremendously outside of the main role of
peter parker he's the single most
important character in this film and he
absolutely hits it out of the park
hammering home a profound message to all
of those watching as well as peter
parker at this film's closing moments
one that i'm sure he now wishes he had
heeded in retrospect
while this film has its flaws many of
which i touched on here i still think
this take on the spider-man story had a
lot to say a lot of interesting things
to say when i first saw this in theaters
at 20 years of age i was in the middle
of failing my second year of college
after having to repeat my first year
already i didn't feel like i had a
promising future and in addition to that
when i went to see this film i did so
not with my brothers and family like i
had done with the sam raimi films but
instead with my friends my peers during
that time i didn't know what i was going
to do with my life and everyone around
me seemed to either be doing extremely
well or already after graduating and
looking back on my friend of mine now
while watching this film i was in a very
negative place and in many respects
unjustifiably wanted this film not to be
its own thing but to instead provide me
with the exact same experience i had
when i was at a happier point in my life
in other words i think i was living in
the past demanding of this film and
experience i already had with raymie and
one that it had no intention of trying
to replicate and so while i can say this
film is perfect and does in fact have a
lot of flaws i'm also not a struggling
20 year old kid that's scared of his
future anymore i can see and appreciate
the filmmaking and dedication for this
character that both mark webb and andrew
garfield so lovingly adapted into a
fresh coming-of-age tale that i in
actuality had i been in the right frame
of mind to receive its message would
have been the perfect story for me to
learn from as a young adult
and still to this day
has a lot to offer
it's a great movie and much better than
so so many people giving credit for
[Music]
the amazing spider-man 2.
i really like this movie i think there
are a lot of brilliant things in this
movie i will spend most of my time
talking about this movie exploring its
criminally underrated positives but i
came across something that so perfectly
highlights one of the main issues with
these films so succinctly that i
absolutely had to share it with you all
right off the bat because i thought it
was hilarious
so one of the most viewed videos
concerning the amazing spider-man 2 on
youtube is this one uploaded by ign say
what you want about ign but in the eyes
big corporations like sony they are an
important part of their marketing for
their films online and the video they
uploaded was called the amazing
spider-man 2 the first 10 minutes with
wonderful comments like this from
frostbitey10 quote this is the best
opening to a spiderman movie hands down
and you know what i'd be inclined to
agree contained within this
reintroduction to spider-man is his
brand new amazing looking suit we get
the introduction to electro the main
villain of this story all the while
spidey tries to stop paul giamatti's
rhino in his tracks during a period of
time he's supposed to be at his
graduation which as an opener besides
having all the benefits and trappings of
a perfect introduction to some
characters we'll see later it also sets
up a really emotional and profound
speech to hit peter with at the end of
the film following the horrific tragedy
that follows bookending the narrative
nicely i love this opening sequence it's
stunningly choreographed funnier than
the previous film in a very spider-man
sort of way hits some important
character beats and introduces us to
once again the main antagonist ending on
an exchange between ant-man peter that
seems like a harmless interaction at
first but in fact speaks to the heart of
this film follow the path make your own
trail it's a brilliant opener and
totally deserving of every single one of
those
207 million views it boasts
if not for one teeny tiny problem
those aren't the first 10 minutes of the
film
these are
that's a pretty tough thing to say to me
catching up with everyone's favorite
characters from these films richard and
mary parker as their backstory continues
boasting sequences of scenes and set
pieces more closely related to the jason
bourne or james bond franchises we watch
as these two continue their story from
the first film as they do secret agent
file uploads on a laptop about a mile in
the sky now with that said while this
doesn't feel at all like a spider-man
film yet i don't want to gatekeep any
artist's desire to explore what
spider-man might mean to them however
this scene doesn't feel like the rest of
the film either and so i wonder if ign
and sony wish that this was the first 10
minutes of the film and that this spy
stuff wasn't or if it sincerely was just
an accident either way ign that is false
advertising
holding you accountable and you know
what this would be fine if it didn't
connect intrinsically to this film but
much like the last one it does and
unfortunately it's in the worst way
possible in this film specifically i
won't harp on about this too much but
the fact that peter turns out not to be
an everyman but in fact the son of a
secret scientific spy father that
created the spiders that bit him in the
first place and that the only reason he
was able to become spider-man was
because of his blood all of that is to
say that it really takes from what i see
as the main value of this character that
anyone could wear the mask it's what
makes it so powerful and it's a shame
because i actually liked this movie more
than the first one and by a wide margin
which i did not expect because this is
the movie people have been clowning on
for years and years many have considered
this film to be the worst spider-man
film it didn't do well enough in
theaters to justify a third film and to
be completely clear this film has more
flaws in the first film so how is it
possible that i liked it more
[Music]
hey i'm sorry i'm running a bit late i
got stuck in some traffic gwen and
peter's relationship in these films is
something i really don't think i fully
appreciated when i first watched them
back in the mid-2010s and even looking
back now i feel like a lot of people
still sleep on this dynamic i look at
mary jane and peter from the original
films and think yes i think they work
well together but i wasn't ever really
invested in a meaningful way it was
always sort of set dressing and it
wasn't just them looking ahead with mj
in the mcu with holland's peter i liked
their relationship and find it very
believable however gwen stacy and peter
parker's relationship in these films
would be enough to carry the film even
if you were to take out the spider-man
aspect of it if this wasn't a spider-man
flick this dynamic still works and i
think that's when you truly know you
have something special on your hands
here obviously andrew garfield and emma
stone are two incredibly charismatic and
talented performers and their dynamic
came across as beautifully authentic
thanks in no small part to them dating
during the filming of these films
however upon revisiting the movies of
toby andrew and eventually tom holland
next week i sat down with my partner who
hadn't seen most of these films and none
of the andrew garfield ones and you know
what these andrew garfield films turned
out to be her absolute favorites and she
thinks that because of the two lead
characters dynamic and rapport they make
these movies feel like they have weight
and they have consequences the way they
look at each other the way they walk
talk and make decisions with one another
it all feels so intoxicatingly genuine
and elevates this film far above what it
otherwise would be without it i think
and while i know for some their
relationship might have been a bit too
cute or meandering at times from a
dialogue perspective i genuinely believe
that their relationship is the
cornerstone of this film and indeed the
first one too one that without these
films just wouldn't work and the reason
why this dynamic is so perfect
is because it acts a vital and intense
question about responsibility should she
know
[Music]
this film is better than the first film
and while i know a lot of people don't
like electro and harry osborn in this
film i thought they delivered and
executed upon its themes exceptionally
well in a much more sophisticated way
than i recalled and i think more than
any other critic has been able to give
credit for but how i hear you asking
well allow me to explain what i've
noticed electro or max dylan is an
unassuming and deeply troubled man that
becomes endowed with tremendous
electrical abilities he shares a number
of scenes with spider-man both before
and after becoming electro with each
subsequent encounter becoming more and
more violent this is a character whose
entire being is defined by spider-man
because
he has nothing else he doesn't see
himself as worth anything initially
enamored by him and showing deep
appreciation for him eventually electro
comes to despise spider-man and what he
believes he stands for now harry osborne
on the other hand not many people liked
him in this film he looks weird at the
end and his relationship with peter
seems dubious at best considering he
wasn't mentioned at all in the first
film and having just come off the back
of three films where james franco helped
us get to know the character of harry
osborn for this version of harry to
randomly show up out of nowhere and
expect us to believe he's peter's best
friend is a tall ask however i think
what he offers this film is still
brilliant harry represents peter's past
and present he's a direct relationship
peter has that's disconnected from his
role as spider-man having grown up with
peter as we see towards the beginning of
this film we come to learn that he has a
deep appreciation for peter however much
like max dylan did with spider-man over
the course of this film harry feels
slighted and let down by peter in the
moments where he feels like he needed
him the most he feels betrayed by peter
leading to this scene
this entire film is about peter parker
and spider-man making the right choices
now that he has chosen to take the
responsibility as both spider-man and
peter parker people depend on him and
bad things would happen if he was to
make the wrong choices and very early on
in the film peter exercises one of those
choices by breaking up with gwen stacy
in his mind trying to do the right thing
trying to do right by her father however
during the run time of this film we see
him struggle to keep the promises he's
made and to stick to the decisions he's
committed himself to he keeps trying to
see gwen gets back with her doesn't stop
looking for his parents and as a result
causes his aunt may to feel inadequate
he's trying to have this life both ways
he's trying to have all the pros of
spider-man which this movie goes to
tremendous lengths to glorify all the
while he also tries to have everything
he wants as peter parker in short he
wants it both ways and this aspect of
the film comes to its romantic height in
this moment where peter in an effort to
reconnect with gwen before she moves
away forever sends her a message
you're wrong about us being on different
paths
this exact exchange with gwen mirrors
perfectly the advice aunt may gave to
peter at the beginning of this film
right after he graduated using uncle
ben's word she encouraged peter to blaze
his own trail however this advice while
perfectly innocent his naive
interpretation offset advice leads peter
onto making the worst decision of his
young life you can't be here right now
i'm not messing around you can't be here
right now
[Music]
the ending of the amazing spider-man 2
does not pull its punches this film has
been asking what the ramifications of
not truly respecting and understanding
the responsibility you have might be and
boy does it work in that regard max
dylan someone that felt betrayed by
spider-man harry osborn someone that
felt betrayed by both peter and
spider-man joined forces as a wonderful
thematic illustration of peter's
failings in trying to find balance in
his life gwen is the goal she always has
been and in his haste to have everything
he's ever wanted unfortunately once
quinn gets wrapped up in this danger
dylan and osborne both act as the
sobering reality check peter created for
himself by confiding in and wishing to
be with gwen in the first place
concluding with everything being torn
away from him
to me gwen stacy in these films is by
far the best of every love interest
depicted in any spider-man related film
on top of feeling like a real character
she brought a competence and warmth to
every scene she was a part of in being
who she was she fundamentally helped
peter become the man he is today even
saving him and working with him to solve
complex problems with life and death in
the balance
she was brave
she was loving
and she was his path
i think the part of this film that has
stuck with me the longest is the
question it asks at the very end
throughout these two films there have
been questions asked of both peter and
us the audience however throughout this
film it broadly concerned itself with
one question
can peter find balance in his life and
he couldn't
he failed
the hero failed to protect and uphold
what was most important to him and so
part of him now dies as a result how can
he go on how can he live with himself
this is the best question asked in the
film and personally
i found its answer not only profound but
invaluable as an outlook towards an
uncertain and scary future
there will be dark days ahead of us too
there will be days where you feel all
alone and that's when hope is needed
most no matter how buried it gets or how
lost you feel you must promise
that you will hold on to hope
keep it alive we have to be greater than
what we suffer my wish for you
is to become hope
people need that
and even if we fail hey spider-man
what better way is there till
andrew garfield spider-man i think is
the single most relatable spider-man out
of the main three dealing with some of
the most harrowing of circumstances
while still managing to find the
strength to greet another day with
courage as an actor andrew to me is the
single best ever to don the mask he's
proven himself not only to hold this
character near and dear to his heart for
his entire life he's not only given us
lasting and beautiful performances but
he also for those projects took less pay
than both tom and toby by considerable
margins for his first two films tom
holland was paid over five million
dollars for toby's first two films he
was paid north of 20 million dollars
for andrew he was paid 1.5 and given the
scope of his performances in these films
as well as what they grossed in addition
to his dedication to the spider-man
franchise i at the very least wanted to
give these films the praise i thought
they deserved i genuinely believe that
enough people have criticized these
films they're not perfect and i think we
all know that but consider this just
another one of the small voices out
there that say this while flawed
is still an amazing spider-man franchise
[Music]
[Music]